counting some numbers take one here we
go are you ready
all right here we go hey brady you
caught me in the rain uh here's your
numbers
hi brady
jodie foster forever
okay here we go
testing
all right this is cgp gray zero to nine
oh i'm only need a zero
zero
zero
or maybe you want
o
or
not
nine
eight
let me get a bit closer
okay
zero
five three
three point one four one five nine two
six five three five eight nine seven
nine three two three eight four six here
we go
zero
one the dogs the dogs have something to
say about this well anyway if you're
doing binary you're done now but uh
maybe we should do more
five
three
one all right it's really awkward doing
a nice frame in there for you
hi
three
four
five
i didn't think this through
um
how am i gonna do six i like the number
eight because it's infinity
one
five
[Music]
six
nine
two
three
four zero
one
two
three
zero
one
five
five
then i'll make it a little bit
interesting for you
nine
nine
i'll do that again without the sirens in
the background
nine
michael stevens
hot set michael it's a hot set gone
one two three
four five
eight
nine
that was really convenient and one a
little slower just in case
and again but a little faster two six
four double three eight three two seven
nine five zero two double eight four one
nine seven one six nine three double
nine three seven five one zero eight
nine
zero
zero i don't know why i did the hand
thing that was weird and creepy congrats
number five
nine
nine
nine
nine
ten
nine ten he didn't need ten i'm
squinting from the son of mine
eight
nine
zero i almost said ten seven eight nine
ten nine
ten
nine
ten
eleven eleven
zero
okay zero
nine
almost said ten almost
eight
nine
zero
seven
eight
nine
five eight two zero nine seven four nine
double four five nine two three zero
seven eight one six four zero six
[Applause]
seven
eight
nine
ten
and if you want to do hexadecimal
we can add a couple more a
b
c
d
e
there you go
six i forgot f
f
one
one
i don't know where the other one went
seven eight nine zero b me johnny's
destiny
[Music]
[Laughter]
zero six two eight six two eight zero
double nine eight six two eight zero
three four eight two five three four two
double one seven zero six seven nine
love you guys
eight
nine
nine
there you go
nine
zero
seven eight nine
three
point
point
congratulations
man hopefully that's good sorry for the
delay i love you very much goodbye eight
nine
there you go brady
how do people count
all right there bye
zero